you set the pop-up
pop-up so you apply on this pop-up
what happens next all i did on the
pop-up all i did was click put me on
pause so i'm inside the peace corps
website you know i'll wait for 72 hours
before and i'll give someone a chance to
call me about 24 hours later i get a
phone call and the phone call is to an
old school flip phone if you remember
those
yeah and all it says is 703 i don't know
what 703 is but it doesn't say blocked
it doesn't say unlisted it doesn't say
the full number it just says 703 so i
pick it up on the other line is some
nice person a lady who basically says
hey are you andrew bustamante did you
apply for this position and you know i
said yes to all those things she was
like hey it seems like you might be a
good fit for a role in national security
would that be something that interests
you and then we have a very short
conversation that basically just
verifies i am who i said i was on the on
online and that i would be interested in
national security position they don't
say who or who with did you ask i did i
said who was it with and she said we're
not in a position to disclose that right
now but she did say we would like to
interview in person in washington dc
would you be amenable to that uh and
again 27 year old 27 year old single
male everything she asked me was yes
yeah i'm down let's do it let's go so
then she said we're going to send you a
ticket and a rental car reservation a
hotel reservation it'll be at your house
overnight and then just follow those
instructions and and we'll see you in
d.c to virginia oh dc yeah so for me i'm
in i'm in montana at the time
and i think to myself
not never gonna happen nothing's gonna
show up that that was just a weird crank
like whatever people are just trying
stupid you legitimately didn't think it
was a real thing because i was a nuclear
missile officer for the air force too so
this just seemed to me like uh this
could have been anything
there's not a lot of me
that i'm a nuclear missile
come on guys
vinnie did the same thing he was a
nuclear
uh officer in the air force i don't
think he's just qualified as hell no but
wait a minute vinnie was a nuclear
officer in the air force vincent
o'shanna the same guy who dresses up as
alfonso ramirez and raids nancy pelosi's
office was a former nuclear missile
officer
we have to verify that we're a cool
bunch of crazies
that's true
okay so so you're in montana they send
the car you're thinking there's no way
that someone's trying to pull a prank on
you and then i get i get an overnight
package that has everything she said it
would have with a with a physical paper
ticket that has me in dc like two months
later
and i go and i go and i follow
everything the recruiting process
recruiting process kicks off now for
most people that recruiting process is
somewhere between nine and 18 months
because it takes so long for the
security clearance to come through i
already had the clearance so my my
interview process happened in about six
months not because again not because i
was smart but just because
the majority of the work was done they
had my whole military background they
knew that i was a chinese speaker
they knew i had nuclear missile uh
knowledge and they knew that i was uh
and they knew that i was now let me ask
you you say because i'm not smart are
you right you know how sometimes we're
kind of like well i'm not the smartest
guy you know exactly we're kind of
playing that i'm not that smart to not
be a threat because we want to be not a
threat and you're naturally trying to
you've got you're not smart multiple
times
yeah this air force nuclear scientist
over here not that smart yeah but no but
but the part a part of
that is for me
i don't know if i want cia to not
recruit
smart people like you i don't want them
to go recruit like just anybody off the
street so
you know there's there's a when you when
i worked at morgan stanley dean witter
they we went through a bunch of
interview process of course nothing like
it in military you didn't go through
interview pro i was a hammer mechanic so
you don't become a hummer mechanic
needing a process just here's a wrench
go right
but when when i did go through morgan
stanley then it was like one interview
two interview you're not accustomed to
that many interviews and you're taking
tests after test after test after test
after test what were some of the tests
you took with them was it
more mental now i'm assuming none of it
was probably physical because if you're
coming from air force they already know
you're somewhat taking care of yourself
what were some of the tests you went
through yeah so it's a psychological
battery it's a it's a psychological
battery almost exclusively so i had a
2.4 gpa coming out of college which is
well below what they say you have to
have to apply to cia they say you have a
minimum of 3.5
and then i went on and got a graduate
degree at university south florida and i
did i did well in my graduate studies
mainly because i wanted to prove to
myself that i was smarter than i was in
college i was just chasing tail in
college and we all suck grade wise when
you spend late nights on benders and
tail
but
the application process for cia looks
like personal interviews where they're
basically pressure testing your ability
to work under fire and and be flexible
with the situation and then they pair
that with psychological interviews some
of those psychological interviews or
some of those psychological tests test
your personality others test your
your cognitive reasoning other ones
actually quantify your ability to take
disparate information and then combine
it into something useful so i did well i
must have done well enough in those
tests to be moved forward but i didn't
expect at any point to actually make it
to the next round because in my in the
back of my head i'm thinking
like i was i barely graduated college
yeah granted i went to a nice college i
went to a challenge in college but i
still didn't get great grades and i
wasn't a 4.0 student in high school i am
i am the
the model uh get distracted by things
fun and life kind of person just turns
out after i got in that is exactly what
cia is looking for the undercover
element of cia the directorate of
operations the national clandestine
service the people whose job it is to go
out there meet and recruit as sources
and spies
those people need to be
flexible social and up for the next big
adventure
your analysts
your scientists your tech wizards you
need those people
are super smart and
borderline uh asperger's they don't
always want to go outside they don't
want to deal with people hardcore
introverts great point that that do a
different job that totally makes sense
so it makes sense where
uh
it is almost the non-threat as well it's
a form of a non-threat based on how
you're explaining it so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]